[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con mi nombre es
ángela gómez y hoy hablaremos de una de
las consecuencias que ha dejado el
contexto de la pandemia de kobe 19 y
para algunas personas sabe que han
padecido el virus sé que han expresado
sufrir y es la ansiedad para ello nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france24 doctor un saludo para usted
y según los expertos en salud mental en
américa latina ante la incertidumbre
sobre el futuro aumentó la frecuencia de
síntomas de ansiedad en la población por
el inicio de la pandemia esto es una
realidad
si definitivamente esta situación de
pandemia ha desnudado pues estas
enfermedades mentales y reconocer que el
sentimiento de ansiedad y depresión son
situaciones normales dentro de la
cotidianidad de los seres humanos el
incremento de las noticias negativas
encierro y el entornos familiares y
sociales que se han visto afectados para
la pandemia han magnificado esta
situación es decir que la ansiedad se ha
generalizado y realmente es uno de los
problemas más que tenemos al que
enfrentar en esta pandemia bueno
justamente sentir ansiedad ocasional no
es algo tan extraño tan difícil es
habitual en la vida de las personas cuál
es la diferencia entre esa ansiedad que
conocíamos antes de la pandemia y la que
conocemos ahora después de la crisis
sanitaria como podemos identificarlas
es cuando afecta nuestra cotidianidad la
ansiedad cuando hace parte y la ansiedad
y la depresión interfieren en nuestra
vida diaria en nuestras actividades y
todo gira en torno a las situaciones
pesimistas pues interfiere con la normal
desarrollo de la personalidad y aquí es
donde se debe intervenir el tener
ansiedad tener nervios es algo usual es
algo natural pero no puede interferir
con la cotidianidad y con las
actividades mínimas de una persona en su
desarrollo social ahí es cuando
requerimos tratamiento o buscar una
orientación profesional mire al inicio
de la pandemia la organización
panamericana de la salud advirtió que
existía la posibilidad que las personas
se sintieran más estresadas y
preocupadas durante esta emergencia de
salud pública así que cuál ha sido la
población que más ha padecido la
ansiedad como consecuencia
hay varios grupos poblacionales de
interés o uno son los trabajadores de la
salud estar enfrentados a la pandemia
antes de la una ver los fallecimientos
la incapacidad para poder ayudar a gente
atrae unos grandes problemas en nosotros
través de la salud acerca de la salud
mental las otras son las personas
vulnerables aquellas personas que por
sus situaciones médicas han estado en
encierros durante mucho tiempo eso trae
gente genera ansiedad y otro grupo muy
importante son los niños y adolescentes
que han perdido su dinámica social ha
estado encerrado en las casas haciendo
estudios a distancia pero han perdido
ese contacto social y hemos visto el
incremento en enferma mental y el
ansiedad en la población infantil y
adolescente somos varios delitos
poblacionales emoción afectados y por
eso es necesario exteriorizar este
problema para poder filmar
cuando debe ser tratada clínicamente la
ansiedad y cómo puede atacarse cuál
sería su recomendación
hay tres cosas que podríamos hacer
inicialmente uno es editar la
sobreinformación lo segundo es
adaptarnos a la normalidad y lo tercero
es evitar estas famous y estas noticias
pesimistas que a través de las redes
sociales pueden contaminar nos acerca de
la dinámica normal para eso que la
información tiene que ser necesario y
suficiente pero no excesiva y verificar
estos pequeños con fuentes de
información que sean reales y buscar
ayuda cuando se sienta la intervención
ir a un psicólogo buscar un profesional
en salud mental no lo hace cuando uno
tenga una enfermedad grave mental es
ante estas situaciones de ansiedad inter
frena cotinina donde ellos nos pueden
ayudar bueno y ya para el cierre para
nuestros televidentes o cómo se puede
hacer tangible esta ansiedad para
detectarla en nuestros seres queridos
como sabemos que se está atravesando y
cuáles son las señales de alarma
la ansiedad y la depresión son fenómenos
que se puede recomenzar por ejemplo
cuando las personas no comen bien no
consiguen el sueño y tienen la habilidad
emocional lloran fácilmente cuando las
personas interfieren su continuidad o
cuando están todo el tiempo pendiente de
las noticias acerca de la pandemia y
generándose miedos que le permiten la
socialización es importante reconocerlo
para que podamos intervenir lo
tempranamente doctor muchas gracias a
ustedes ya nuestros televidentes sigan
conectados en france 24 buenos días
[Música]